welcome Mahault this will be the final of
the
uh presentation sessions in the
symposium
this is Mal abrasan with the
presentation shared pretensions in
active inference so thank you Mao to you
and you're the first you're the first to
join with an AI Steward slash Guardian
awesome shall I share my screen yes
Let's do let's do let's do
a second I'm looking for a window
a thing this will do
okay so can you see the screen
Yep looks good thank you
awesome so unfortunately
I imagine
that you are seeing the entire screen
and not just the presentation I
apologize about that but I got it it's
it's cropped I got it okay wonderful
thank you
all right so
welcome to the presentation on shared
protection under active inference we're
going to cover a lot of topics
um shall I introduce myself a little bit
um
or have you already done that
awesome so my name is I'm a PhD student
in cognitive Computing I work in active
inference in the interaction between uh
social sciences uh philosophy
Consciousness science and artificial
intelligence
um we're going to start a presentation
on protection potential and active
inference so I'm going to define a lot
of terms it's going to deal into
um the last philosophy terms that are
very deep
um and uh so let's get started if you
will just give me one small second
and we're back
so shared retention is a term derived
from phenomenology and it refers to the
shared anticipation of future events
among a group of individuals this
philosophical study you've experienced
and Consciousness becomes particularly
interesting when we consider it in the
context of active inference
when we combine these two concepts we
get a powerful tool for understanding
how groups of individuals can coordinate
their actions and work towards a common
goal this is the main focus of the
discussion today so imagine
a group of people planning a trip
they all share a common goal to have a
successful and enjoyable trip
the shared goal forms the basis of their
shared protection they all anticipate
future events related to the trip such
as booking tickets packing their bags
and visiting various attractions
as they start to take actions towards
their goal they're also engaging in
active inference they're making
predictions about what will happen next
and then adjusting these predictions
based on what actually happens so for
example they might predict at a certain
flight will be the cheapest based on
their past experiences but when they
actually check the prices they find that
another flight is cheaper
so they adjust their prediction and book
the other flight
this constant cycle of prediction and
adjustment Guided by their shared
protection helps the group coordinate
their actions and make their trip to
success
so we're going to delve deeper into the
concepts and explore the role of past
experiences known as retentions in
shaping our current knowledge and future
predictions
explain let's explain first the concept
of retentions retention is a key
component of time Consciousness that
retains the past trajectory of a
temporal object
it's the preservation of the content of
a now past highlighted datum in our
present consciousness
a highletic datum refers to the raw
uninterpreted Sensations that arise in
our consciousness
when we retain these data
we are essentially keeping a record of
past Sensations and experiences that can
inform our present and our future
actions
inactive inference we can formalize
retention by thinking of moments as
binning of states which are bounds to a
hierarchical state
this way retention is seen as the
bidding which becomes the current state
informing the next expected state
to further connect retention with active
inference we can consider the way in
which retention plays a role in updating
an agent's belief and generative model
the past experiences influence the
current expectations and actions thus
shaping the agent's understanding of the
world and the future
so let's consider a practical example to
illustrate this concept if you had a
good experience at a particular
restaurant you might choose to go there
again in the future
your past experience influences your
future decision in hustling temporal
phenomenology we would think about much
shorter time scale but if we extend this
concept we can see a much larger
structure whereing the retention is
simply the past state
it's like having a mental node that says
this place is good and this is how an
example of retention works in your
everyday life
they're not merely representation or
memories but presentations of a
temporally extended present
which distinguishes them from
Recollections this involves the
presentation of some already constituted
content in conscious experience
retentions also play a crucial role in
mapping past knowledge onto current
beliefs contributing contributing to the
development of shared narratives or
goals that we will delve into in the
rest of the presentation
they can be former now points and the
current awareness of the past and far
sedimented retentions can be engraved in
scripts or deep temporal priors or more
fluid deonta cues
this phenomenon corresponds to a
specific application of message passing
between agents in the present moment and
in the sensorium
retentions and protentions may also
emerge jointly within a group
forming a collective understanding that
transcends individual perspectives
protentions as we saw
refer to the anticipation of future
events based on past experiences and
current knowledge
it's thus forward look it's the
forward-looking counterpart to retention
which is backward looking
protection is the anticipation of future
trajectories of a temporal object
it's the process of looking ahead
predicting what's to come based on what
has been and what currently is
so in active inference it could be
formalized by considering the future
states that are expected based on the
current state and past States
retention is thus the anticipation
guiding the next action
you can consider the way in which
protention plays a role in updating an
agent's beliefs and generative models
influencing the actions and thus shaping
the agent's understanding of the world
ends the future
so for instance if you see dark clouds
in the sky you might anticipate that
it's going to rain and decide to carry
an umbrella this anticipation of future
events is protention it's also going to
determine whether or not you're what
when you go outside and therefore
whether or not you expect to be wet
your brain is constantly making
predictions about what's going to happen
next
so let's put this in the context of
temporal flow
which ties together those concepts of
Primal Impressions and we will see
retention and retention
temporal flow is the structure that
represents the continuous progression of
time from the past through the present
and into the future
agents are constantly revising their
generative models and they do this by
integrating the observations which we
could refer to here as Primal
impressions
this updating process is a balancing act
between maintaining the predictive
density of the agent's current beliefs
and adapting to new information
retentions and protection structure a
time for a given agent creating a
framework that shapes their perception
and anticipation
different agents or systems will
exhibits
varying qualities and quantities of
retention and protection which resembles
something like Mike Levin's concept of
cognitive like
so given the presence of retention we
can anticipate a potential Horizon
not merely as an arbitrary expectation
students are thus the point at which
agents beliefs about the world are
updated to match their current
observations which leads to a more
accurate understanding of the
environment and allows for more
effective goal-directed Behavior
Primal impressions are the Fulfillment
of a protention which is the time-bound
Nexus of perception and existence
is it is resolved all right sorry it is
the result probability that redefines
the local radiant
it's in primary impression that reality
collapses
the Primal impression is thus mode
modeled as the essential Bayesian
cognitive moment
it is the juxtaposition of Prior beliefs
or retentions
with ongoing sensory information in an
unfolding future oriented present
retention
so now we have a description of temporal
thickness from the nominology which is
compatible with generative modeling and
active influence agents
for hustle this flow of conscious
experience is primarily made up of
Sensations that dwell up in a raw
uninterpreted form that we called
earlier highlighting data
so this data is the now phase of a
temporal object it is formatted
according to the eidetic or cognitive
laws of consciousness
this is specifically relative to Inner
time
you can understand how temporal Tempo
flow structures how agents are able to
make choices act to self-evidence
connect the passive structure with the
active component of decision making or
goal Pursuit
individuals have drives and teleology
insofar as they have preferences
these preferences are protented goals
reach towards by what we would call
potentially the Fiat
where in the Fiat constitute the willed
act towards a desire
so the Fulfillment of retention by Fiat
drives the agent towards the teleology
across a trail set
in a retentional extension
more information is a matter so the
longer your retention the more
information can be caught in a moment
as individuals amass enough information
they can then find a structure to the
information which becomes a map rather
than a territory it is computationally
more efficient than the sum of all the
information amongst
this new state of information may lead
individuals closer to a shared goal the
information a mass turns into an
emergent whole of the retention which
grabs focus at the present moment
because it seems to bring signals to the
model that the potential role is closer
and is computationally simpler to retain
so sharing of retentions and protections
among group members any social context
can facilitate coordination and the
achievement of a shared goal
by aligning their beliefs about the past
or retentions and expectations about the
future or pretensions group members can
better predict each other's actions and
intentions
this allows them to work together more
effectively
in some cases group members may have
retentions and protentions that align
naturally due to Common experiences or
understanding even without active
communication
however group members often actively
communicate their retentions and
protentions aligning their beliefs and
expectations through dialogue and
interaction
thereby
enhancing their ability to predict each
other's actions and intentions
retentions and protections may also
emerge jointly within the group not
confined to any individual agents umwelt
forming a collective understanding that
transcends individual perspectives
this complex interplay of individual and
Collective Dynamics can be explored
further in hierarchical genetic models
encompassing resonant cognitive models
communication and even joint emergence
the structure of time Consciousness
encapsulated in retention and protection
thus plays a significant role in the
emergence of shared potentials
as agents retain and process similar
elements from their environment they can
co-compute share protections by mapping
each other's cognitive Pathways and
building upon one another's trails
this process is formalized by Bayesian
updating
um
the relationship between the topology of
protensions and the expectation gradient
as well as the role of retention in
mapping past knowledge on the current
beliefs plays a role in development of
shared narratives and goals
we can use this to get a deeper insight
into the processes that drive the
emergence of collective Behavior and the
development of shared understanding
among agents
there's no better way to do it than
using active inference by extending
generative models of individual agents
to account for the beliefs and goals of
other agents
this is the kin2 theory of mind it
enables them to anticipate and adapt to
the actions of their peers by offloading
to the group
so
we discussed a little bit earlier shared
goals
potential goals are future oriented
objectives that individuals or groups
strive to achieve
they're not just mere desires but
they're actively pursued through the act
of will that we called earlier Fiat
the Fulfillment of a pretension drives
the agent towards the teleology that
trail set we discussed
of a prediction entails less surprises
and therefore the agent's self-evidences
by seeking to accurately predict their
surroundings
agents like the series of actions or
policies which generate transitions
between states that produce expected
observations so through the choice of
policy an individual can reach their
protented goal by minimizing the
expected free energy that a given policy
affords them this seems pretty Central
and simple in terms of active inference
so farther protections are represented
by the policies of longer time depth
in a hierarchical model this corresponds
to a policy tied to a higher level
action in a slower time scale
the choice of policies driven by the
expected free energy of that higher
order policy or the entire multi-scale
generative model is based on the agent's
preferences allowing an agent to conduct
gold directed behaviors across temporal
scales
so this is where we can cash out
um Jeff yoshimi's Trail sets where
agents assimilate actions into the
anticipated continuity of objects in
their surrounding world
this is simulation
ensures a smoother understanding of the
environment and helps agents adapt
effectively near protensions act as the
near present contextual proximity and
the far pretensions rely on passive
synthesis of deontic cues which are
sedimented retentions in the environment
the preferences of the agents aligned by
policies correspond to attracting sets
which in the socio-cognitive setting can
be instantiated as narratives having
shared narrative is a necessary aspect
of any exchange between artifacts people
institutions that have some kind of
attracting set
generalized synchrony which we will
discuss a little bit later as well
so a team working on a project has a
potential goal to complete the project
successfully
the shared narrative might be the
project plan that guides their actions
it's like everyone in the team has a
shared story about what they're trying
to achieve and how they're going to do
it
the relationship between current states
and future observations is captured
within the B Matrix transitions
this Matrix represents the probability
of transitioning to a new state based on
the current state so the B Matrix
transition
and the a matrix is utilized to
determine which new observations is most
likely to occur given the current state
and potential transitions
in the Assyrian framework the
expectation gradient structure plays a
crucial role in defining the depth and
fulfillment of pretensions
the structure represents the varying
degrees of certainty and confidence
agents have in their predictions about
future States
the topology thus is inter and the
arrangements is interrelation I'm sorry
or there is an interrelation between the
protentions or the arrangements of
future expectations which is
proportional to the expectation gradient
the higher the gradient the more
detailed and accurate the pretensions
are likely to be
the potential Horizon represents the
static states of the expected futures of
the temporal object while the
continuation Horizon is The Amalgamated
Trail of the temporal object
potential and continuation Horizons are
carried in protentions while the
imminent Horizon consists of the Primal
impressions
so agents can coordinate through
co-construction where agents or
individuals interact and collaborate to
build this shared understanding and
shared goals
this process is deeply interconnected
within a complex web where agents
typically coexist with other agents or
subjects
forming the collective often referred to
as multi-aged groups swarm ensembles or
assemblage
by aligning their beliefs to the signal
found within their Niche they can better
adapt to the environment and develop a
shared understanding of their
surroundings
sharing information with other agents is
beneficial as it allows them to trust
one another and pull their resources
this collaborative approach is
preferable to a conflict-driven scenario
in which every other agent is perceived
as a potential source of risk and
surprising
by sharing information agents could
collectively construct a more accurate
representation of their environment
leading to more effective
decision-making in action
through these interactions shared
narratives and goals can emerge from a
co-construction of the world and each
agent's generated model
so these narratives and roles are the
result of dynamic process that in fact
can be mathematically modeled through
the equations that we introduce in the
paper that is that this presentation is
based on but that I will present a
little bit later
they capture the process of mutual
learning where agents adapt their
generative model based on the
information gathered from their
interactions with others
agents may start off with slightly or
greatly diverging generative model so in
order to minimize surprise there will be
a natural alignment within a group as
agents adapt to the evolving dynamics of
their environment and social contexts
for example again consider this team
working on the project
even if you have your own understanding
of the model or of the project you'll
interact and share information and learn
from each other and then adapt the model
over time you'll develop a shared
understanding of the project and a
shared goal for its completion
this is an instance of co-construction
it's like building a house together
where everyone contributes to the final
structure
the emergence of shared narratives and
the learning and recognition of them may
be made more efficient through certain
mechanisms such as language
in an experiment Illustrated uh in a
paper that
um Carl was on
um two agents share the same sensorium
ask each other's questions I think it's
a paper on 20 questions and Emma homes
um with a shared narrative entailing a
Common Language
this illustrates the market efficiency
and the minimization of free energy
simply by having a shared language a
common ground
so shared protections are common future
anticipations or goals that emerge among
groups of individuals through
co-construction
it allows them to better anticipate each
other's actions and intentions and work
towards a common goal
it's strongly tied to the conscious
efforts of individuals to work towards
that goal
and to effectively create an
organizational structures where we're
engaged in a conversation in an exchange
assuming that this exchange is meant to
align our generative models
so think of for instance the football
team
again they have a shared pretension to
win the match they anticipate each
other's moves and adapt their strategies
based on the ongoing game everyone in
the team has a shared vision of Victory
and they're constantly adjusting their
actions to make it happen
so individuals infer each other's mental
states by observing cues which they can
attribute to hidden causes they use
their own model of or models that they
have learned to recognize about others
this process is known as generalized
synchrony entailing Mutual
predictability and can be interpreted as
a collective minimization of free energy
in a group setting individuals create
cues in the world that direct other
agents attentions towards the same
signals their models of the world
aligned by sharing similar goals and
similar environments and by reinforcing
patterns of sampling reality
so we could we could try to represent
this through polynomials
um and morphisms each agent's
interaction with the environment
corresponds to amorphism and the
collective interaction of all agents can
be represented as a polynomial
so
amorphism sort of if a polynomial p is
defined uh morphism between two
polynomials p and Q consists of a pair
of functions f and g such that F Maps P
of 1 to Q of one
and G Maps P of I to Q of the quantity
one this morphism must satisfy the
commutative the requirements meaning
that the following diagram commutes
um
tier one p ofi maps to Q the quantity I
and tier one maps to Q of one
so we can see how we could create a
framework to further explore the
cooperative and competitive Dynamics
among agents for multiple agents indexed
by I with boundaries p and share
environment boundary Q their interaction
can represent can be represented by a
morphism of polynomials which allows us
to understand the shared protection in
multi-agent systems and provide the
foundation for further exploration of
Cooperative Dynamics
we allow each agent to predict not only
its own behavior but also the behavior
of its Companions and the environment's
response to their actions
so the Dynamics of shared credentials
are really useful here and can be
properly cached out mathematically
so recursive cognition and prediction on
the shared environment of the agent's
actions and response to each other's
actions
we can use sheep theoretic and topless
theoretic approaches to understand
multi-agent systems a multi-agent system
is a system where multiple individuals
or entities interact so for example a
traffic system can be considered a
multi-agent system or different vehicles
or interact
the topos is a category that has both
spatial and logical structure allowing
for the expression of logical
propositions and deductions within it so
we can use these approaches to construct
a coherent understanding of the world
from the perspective of multiple agents
the internal Universe of Agents which
can be seen as mathematical objects
containing beliefs perceptions and
predictions of individual agents are
represented using topoi
these internal universes provide a
foundation for understanding and
representing the complex interactions
and shared understanding among multiple
agents in this Dynamic environment
we try to construct a consensus topos by
patching together the internal universes
or topoi of multiple agents and the idea
is to use the chief theoretic and topos
theoretic structures to build a shared
understanding
so we can thus derive the
synchronization of goal oriented actions
among agents over time and leverage
mathematical insights for category
Theory and generalities generated models
this connection is the mechanism through
which the group synchronizes over time
and ultimately achieves their objective
agents within the system might possess
very levels of certainty in achieving
the objective some may choose to expand
less energy temporarily decelerating
their progress towards the desired
outcome this variation in certainty and
approach leads to the emergence of
different roles within a group with some
agents focusing on computational tasks
while other monitor outcomes are engaged
in different actions in themselves
the nested and distributed structure of
generative models in active inference
allows for the integration of both
short-term and long-term goals agents
with similar or compatible preferences
can coordinate their actions by aligning
their policies and working towards
common narratives
so this alignment reduces the overall
expected free energy of their joint
actions increasing the likelihood of
achieving shared goals and facilitating
and sharing of goals and expectations
among group members
they can learn which allows them to
learn essential role in shaping agents
preferences and strategies over time
agents can gather new experiences and
update their generative model they
refine their preferences and methods for
achieving goals they can influence the
formation and modification of shared
narratives by having different
perspective over different parts of a
goal
here
the the concept of General Life
synchrony is manifested when all agents
have learned compatible or harmonized
aspects of the overall generative model
the synchronization is rooted in the
retentional and potential dynamics of
agents and can be more accurately
described using mathematical models
so in conclusion
we tried to shed light on the concept of
shared potential goals and multi-agent
systems we've emphasized the importance
of understanding this concept as it
plays a crucial role in the coordination
synchronization of Agents actions and
intentions
in the future continuously highlight the
role of cues in the environment and how
they can be simple like marks on the
road or more complex like symbols and
language
the queues become carriers of passive
synthesis fire protections and far
retention and become wasted minus free
energy as they minimize the amount of
any individual has to compute
it also allows us to delve into the
concept of other evidencing in which the
environment is in effect the self and
others must learn to navigate in terms
navigate in terms of others and self
we've provided mathematical models to an
equation standalized dynamics of shared
protections more accurately in terms of
category Theory
we've explored the Dynamics of shared
retentions and retention in higher
Google generative models which reflect
the complex interplay of individuals and
Collective Dynamics
we've encapsulated the structure of time
Consciousness and how that this allows
agents to co-compute Shared protections
by mapping each other's cognitive
pathways
so our approach basically begins an
examination of Hospital temporal
phenomenology integrated with the
hierarchical active inference model
polynomial morphisms and home
polynomials this enables recursive
cognition and prediction of not only an
agent's actions but also the
environment's response to these actions
so I think this comes to the end Daniel
I think I'm literally at 30 minutes
thank you
impeccable thank you Mahault
yeah great uh presentation awesome topic
so
thank you for joining and looking
forward to seeing how the work continues
to develop
all right
farewell Mahault, see you